Happy New Year's to everybody from us here at SmartLess. Every week you already know the drill. One of us brings a guest and the other two don't know and then they're everybody surprised and then when we talk to them and then basically just try to get to us making fun of Bateman. Anyway, it's SmartLess. You're listening to it. Let's go. Smart.
祝大家新年快乐，我们是SmartLess。每周你们都知道流程。我们其中一人带一位嘉宾来，另外两人事先不知道，然后大家都会感到惊喜，接着我们和他们聊天，基本上就是想方设法去取笑Bateman。总之，这就是SmartLess。你们正在收听。开始吧。Smart。
You want to do a snap so we can start chatting? I think our guest is already ready to rock. Good. Let's do it. You start. Have fun. We are rolling. Be safe.
你要拍一下手让我们开始聊天吗？我想我们的嘉宾已经准备好大干一场了。很好。开始吧。你先来。玩得开心。我们正在录制。注意安全。
We were already rolling. We better have been rolling on that, Rob. Yeah, sure. I don't think we can't afford to clear... That's a wham song, isn't it? No, that's Band-Aid. Oh, God. Band-Aid.
我们已经在录制了。Rob，我们最好一直在录制。是的，当然。我不认为我们负担得起……那是威猛乐队（Wham）的歌，对吧？不，那是Band-Aid乐队的。哦，天哪。Band-Aid。
Do they know it's Christmas? Do they know it's Christmas time as a wham song? Wait, but wham? Wasn't wham in it? George Michael was... Andrew Ridgely was not invited. He was not? How do you know?
《他们知道现在是圣诞节吗？》（Do They Know It's Christmas?）是威猛乐队的歌吗？等等，但是威猛乐队？威猛乐队没参与吗？乔治·迈克尔（George Michael）参与了……安德鲁·里奇利（Andrew Ridgely）没被邀请。他没被邀请？你怎么知道？
No, but Magier was in it, Abano was in it. Bob Dylan was in it. He just sold his records. Bob Dylan was not in it because he did the American one. Oh, no, that was the... Yeah. So that was Live Aid, right? I don't know.
不，但是Magier参与了，Abano参与了。鲍勃·迪伦（Bob Dylan）也参与了。他只是卖了他的唱片。鲍勃·迪伦没参与，因为他参加了美国版的。哦，不，那是……是的。那是Live Aid，对吧？我不知道。
That was Band-Aid, which was the precursor to Live Aid. That was when they did the Christmas song that was put together by Bob Geldof, Sir Bob Geldof to you. Sorry. Name the band that Bob Geldof was in, five, four, three, two... Pink Floyd. Boomtown Rats. God, God.
那是Band-Aid，是Live Aid的前身。那是他们演唱那首由鲍勃·格尔多夫（Bob Geldof）——也就是鲍勃·格尔多夫爵士——创作的圣诞歌曲的时候。抱歉。说出鲍勃·格尔多夫所在的乐队，五，四，三，二……平克·弗洛伊德（Pink Floyd）。Boomtown Rats乐队。天哪，天哪。
When did you become such a music dork? Boomtown Rats' biggest hit, Tell Me Why, I Don't Like Mondays, Tell Me Why, I Don't Like... Where does your album drop, Will? It already dropped, and then it smashed. It dropped and smashed all over the... So there was Live Aid, right? Which was the Quincy Jones...
你什么时候变得这么懂音乐了？Boomtown Rats最大的热门歌曲是《告诉我为什么》（Tell Me Why），《我不喜欢星期一》（I Don't Like Mondays），《告诉我为什么》，《我不喜欢……》Will，你的专辑什么时候发布？已经发布了，而且大获成功。它发布后在……到处都火了。所以那是Live Aid，对吧？那是昆西·琼斯（Quincy Jones）……
No, wrong again. Wrong again. Band-Aid was the first one was, Do They Know It's Christmas? Then the Americans did that with Quincy Jones put it together. We are the people. We are the world. Bruce Springsteen famously showed up at a... I'm brand new to the planet.
不，又错了。又错了。Band-Aid是第一个，是《他们知道现在是圣诞节吗？》。然后美国人做了那个，由昆西·琼斯组织。我们是人民。我们是世界。布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀（Bruce Springsteen）很有名地出现在……我对这个星球还很陌生。
That was the Constitution. That was a little earlier. That was a little earlier. That was a little earlier. That's a great song. The Constitution is a great song. Oh, it is such a good... Yeah, that's jazz?
那是宪法。那是早一点的事。那是早一点的事。那是早一点的事。那是一首很棒的歌。宪法是一首很棒的歌。哦，它确实是一首很好的……是的，那是爵士乐？
Sure. The Constitution. Few... But then they did... I watched Live Aid, and here's another great fact about Live Aid. It was both the American and the English version were opened by... Anybody know? Phil Collins opened the one in London, then he got on the Concord Flu to Philly and opened
当然。宪法。少……但后来他们做了……我看了Live Aid，关于Live Aid还有一个很棒的事实。美国版和英国版都是由……有人知道吗？菲尔·柯林斯（Phil Collins）在伦敦开了场，然后他坐协和式飞机去费城，并开了……
the one in Philadelphia. Hmm. What do you mean? Opened this? Like, was the opening act. Oh. But needed the Concord to make that curtain. To make up the time.
费城的那一场。嗯。你是什么意思？开了场？就像，是开场表演。哦。但是需要协和式飞机才能赶上那场演出。为了补回时间。
Yeah. Yeah. Hey, why didn't they stop making the Concord? It was always my dream as a kid to get out of that thing. You could get over to London in like two seconds. I know. From what I understand, the operating... Kind of like brands operate those huge flagship stores.
是的。是的。嘿，他们为什么停止制造协和式飞机了？我小时候的梦想就是坐那玩意儿。你可以在两秒钟内到达伦敦。我知道。据我所知，运营……有点像品牌运营那些巨大的旗舰店。
They don't make any money, like on 57th Street or Fifth Avenue, they don't make any money, but they're good for the brand. That's kind of what the Concord was to Air France and British Columbia. Jesus Christ. I know. Like a fire hose. Did you take a smart pill this morning? I know.
它们不赚钱，比如在第57街或第五大道，它们不赚钱，但对品牌有好处。协和式飞机对法国航空和英国航空来说就是这样。天哪。我知道。就像消防水龙带。你今天早上吃聪明药了吗？我知道。
Or are you back on Coke? Yeah. Fuck. Shut up. Do you not want answers? Jesus Christ. I did fly on it twice. It was quite nice.
还是你又吸可乐了？是的。该死。闭嘴。你不想得到答案吗？天哪。我确实坐过两次。它相当不错。
Did you? The first thing was... What was it like going through the sonic boom? You know, it actually pulsed. There was like this like little pulse every like 30 seconds. Is it like accelerated and went through these speeds and it descended at a really steep, steep angle, I guess, because I had to keep up that speed as long as they could before they came down.
你坐过？第一件事是……穿过音爆是什么感觉？你知道，它实际上有脉冲。每隔30秒左右就有这种小脉冲。它就像加速并穿过这些速度，然后以非常陡峭的角度下降，我想是因为它们必须尽可能长时间地保持那个速度，然后才能降落。
I don't know. That was like a dream of mine to do that as a kid. That's so cool. You got to do that. Let me tell you what a dream is. Is our next guest. I don't see you're pulling up something else to bore us with. Is it about...
我不知道。小时候那就像我的一个梦想。太酷了。你竟然做到了。让我告诉你什么是梦想。就是我们的下一位嘉宾。我没看到你在找别的东西来让我们感到无聊。是关于……
Is it still loading? No, we're just looking up the Concord crash. A few people did... Yeah, just a few. But anyway. Huh. Look at that. Not just...
还在加载吗？不，我们只是在查协和式飞机的坠毁。几个人……是的，只是几个人。但无论如何。呵。看看那个。不仅仅是……
I never said just a few. Are you still reading? Can we carry on? Can we just start now? Giving us something to tighten up in the edit? Yeah. Will, still there? I'm still here.
我从来没说只是几个人。你还在读吗？我们可以继续吗？我们可以现在就开始吗？给我们一些在剪辑中可以收紧的东西？是的。Will，还在吗？我还在。
I'm right here. Let's just go. Sean, this is what Coke does to you. I'm looking at it all the time. You can start to just obsess over something on your phone. What are you? A Coke expert? Jesus, look at this guy.
我就在这儿。我们开始吧。Sean，这就是可乐对你的影响。我一直在看它。你开始在手机上沉迷于某件事。你是什么？可乐专家？天哪，看看这家伙。
We brought in a Coke expert. Guys, listen, tighten up. Let me pull up my notes. Oh, Jesus. Yeah, I do a little bit of research when I invite somebody. Don't say it. So pretend that you know what you're talking about. No, I don't want to trick anybody.
我们请来了一位可乐专家。伙计们，听着，收紧点。让我拿出我的笔记。哦，天哪。是的，我邀请某人时确实会做一点研究。别说出来。所以假装你知道你在说什么。不，我不想欺骗任何人。
All right, now listen. This week's guest is a little something different for us. While, yes, he is an actor, he hasn't always been one, okay? Started out as a political science major. He then became a young cop in training. He then became a motorcycle vagabond. He then broke into Hollywood playing beloved characters such as Zordon, Dalton, Snizzard, and Walter.
好了，现在听着。这周的嘉宾对我们来说有点不同。虽然，是的，他是一位演员，但他并不总是演员，好吗？最初是政治学专业。后来他成了一名年轻的实习警察。然后他成了一名摩托车流浪汉。然后他闯入好莱坞，扮演了诸如Zordon、Dalton、Snizzard和Walter等深受喜爱的角色。
He's an amateur pedicurist. He has only one real eyebrow and three fake fingers, men. It's Brian Xavier Cranston the fifth. I didn't know a lot of that. Three finger, what are you talking about? Three fingers. Look how real they all look right there. He didn't just, yeah.
他是一位业余修脚师。他只有一条真正的眉毛和三根假手指，伙计们。他就是第五代布莱恩·泽维尔·克兰斯顿（Brian Xavier Cranston）。我不知道那么多。三根手指，你在说什么？三根手指。看看它们在那里看起来有多真实。他不仅仅是，是的。
I believed you. I believed you when you said three fake fingers. I only have two fake fingers. He fibbed. Damn it. How are you guys? Oh, Brian. Oh my gosh, it's so nice to see you.
我相信你了。你说三根假手指的时候我相信你了。我只有两根假手指。他撒谎了。该死。你们好吗？哦，布莱恩。哦，天哪，见到你真高兴。
Brian Cranston, how are you, man? Yeah. I'm okay. I'm doing well. I'm excited to be on this smartless show and I can't think of three more smartless guys. Thank you. Between the three of us, we can get one good thought together.
布莱恩·克兰斯顿，你好吗，伙计？是的。我还好。我做得很好。我很兴奋能参加这个Smartless节目，我想不出还有比这更聪明的三个家伙了。谢谢。我们三个加起来，能凑出一个好主意。
Right off the bat, Brian, I want to say, first of all, we're so, gosh, honored to have you here, Jason. What an incredible guest. This is a classy guest here. We don't know each other well, but we've met many times over the years in the hears and there's, and you know, you're one of those guys. You're such, I don't want to embarrass you. You're such an incredibly talented guy, and I mean that because you can and have done
开门见山，布莱恩，我想说，首先，我们非常，天哪，荣幸能请到你，Jason。多么不可思议的嘉宾。这是一个很有档次的嘉宾。我们不太熟，但这些年来我们见过很多次，你知道，你是那种人。你是如此，我不想让你尴尬。你是一个非常有才华的人，我是认真的，因为你可以而且已经做到了
it all. You're super funny. You're a super great actor, and you've done it kind of seemingly, you've just kind of done what you wanted. Does that resonate with you? Do you feel like you've done kind of what you wanted? I was waiting for the third thing, the incredibly handsome part, I guess. That goes without saying, man.
这一切。你超级有趣。你是一位超级伟大的演员，而且你似乎，你只是做了你想做的事。这能引起你的共鸣吗？你觉得你做了你想做的事吗？我在等第三点，那个极其英俊的部分，我想。那是不言而喻的，伙计。
Okay, go. Come on. He put that in the chat window. Did you not, you didn't read that? Yeah. He put it in the chat. You know, maybe when he starts texting you in the middle of the interview. But I mean, I do mean that you are handsome.
好吧，开始吧。来吧。他把它放在聊天窗口里了。你没有，你没读吗？是的。他把它放在聊天里了。你知道，也许当他开始在采访中途给你发短信时。但我的意思是，我是认真的，你很英俊。
Sorry. Did I not mention that? Yeah. No, but I do mean that you really have done so many different things. You have so many different gears, and it's so admirable. And do you, again, go back to my question. Do you feel like you've done it the way you wanted to do it on your terms? Hey, well, all of us began somewhere.
抱歉。我没提到吗？是的。不，但我确实是说你真的做了很多不同的事情。你有这么多不同的档次，这太令人钦佩了。你，再次回到我的问题。你觉得你是按照你想要的方式，按照你自己的条件做到的吗？嘿，好吧，我们所有人都是从某个地方开始的。
And when you first started out as an actor, I mean, you- Just so you know, short answers, Brian, short answers. Some of us are pricks, and some of us are really nice people. Good. There you go. You know, you just learned to say yes right away, because you want to pay your rent and pay for your pictures and resumes in those days and classes and stuff. If you get lucky, like we all have, one job begats another, begats another, and all of
当你刚开始做演员时，我的意思是，你——只是让你知道，简短的回答，布莱恩，简短的回答。我们中有些人是混蛋，有些人是真正的好人。很好。就是这样。你知道，你只是学会了立刻说好，因为你想付房租，付那些日子的照片和简历，还有课程之类的钱。如果你幸运的话，就像我们所有人一样，一份工作带来另一份，再带来另一份，突然之间
a sudden you're in a position where you kind of have actually a little say so in your destiny. And you know, that's a really lucky break for any actor. I think so too, because a lot of people don't like the word luck. I think I completely believe that a lot of it is luck. But luck, there's somebody, there's a smart saying that I don't have right now, but it's- But butcher it. Feel free to butcher it. Yes, you guys will probably straighten me out.
你处于一种对自己的命运有一点发言权的地位。你知道，这对任何演员来说都是一个非常幸运的突破。我也这么认为，因为很多人不喜欢运气这个词。我想我完全相信很大程度上是运气。但是运气，有人，有一个聪明的说法，我现在没有，但它是——但把它搞砸了。随意搞砸它。是的，你们可能会纠正我。
But something about like, luck comes to those who are prepared, something like that. When opportunity meets your preparation, that's- Yeah. Yeah. Luck of, yeah. Oh man, that's amazing. I'm going to get that printed on some plates. Yes.
但大概是说，运气眷顾有准备的人，之类的。当机会遇到你的准备时，那就是——是的。是的。运气，是的。哦，伙计，太棒了。我要把它印在盘子上。是的。
And then break them. We get so much cover with our title. You know, we can just be as dumb or eye-can as I really am with SmartList. Now Brian, in the incredible research that I've done for this interview, I did stumble upon sort of a kindred experience with our upbringing. A, you grew up in Canoga Park and I was just up the street in Woodland Hills. But B, you had a father, I don't know if he's still with us, mine is, but that was also in the industry and had something short of overnight success.
然后打碎它们。我们的标题让我们得到了很多掩护。你知道，在SmartList里，我可以像我真正的那样愚蠢或……。现在布莱恩，在我为这次采访所做的不可思议的研究中，我确实偶然发现了一种与我们的成长经历相似的体验。A，你在Canoga Park长大，我就在街上的Woodland Hills。但B，你有一位父亲，我不知道他是否还在世，我的还在，但他也曾在业内，并且取得了近乎一夜成名的成就。
And I'm wondering how that affected your commitment to your career, to your ambition. Did it give you rocket fuel or did it worry you? It gave me great pause actually because my father led by the ideal that he was destined to become a star and when he didn't become a star, it really destroyed him and through extension it destroyed the family. My whole family just blew up when I was about 11 years old, 12 years old, went to live with my grandparents, we were foreclosed on our house and so this little house in Canoga Park where my mom and dad raised my brother and myself and my little sister, which was home
我想知道这如何影响了你对职业的承诺，对你的抱负。它给了你火箭燃料还是让你担心？它实际上让我非常犹豫，因为我父亲遵循着他注定要成为明星的理想，当他没有成为明星时，这真的摧毁了他，并延伸摧毁了家庭。我整个家庭在我大约11岁、12岁时就分崩离析了，我去和祖父母住，我们的房子被取消抵押赎回权，所以Canoga Park这个小房子，我父母在那里抚养我和我哥哥，还有我的小妹妹，那是家
and which was a sanctuary for us, all of a sudden was non-existent with a big red sticker on the door, foreclosure, bank honed, get out, it was like a scarlet letter. How old were you about? I was 11. And my dad always was working, wasn't working, he had a job, he didn't have a job, he had a good year, a bad year. I remember one year we got a pretty new car and then the following year we got rid of that car and got a really old car and then one year we put in a built-in swimming pool
那是我们的避难所，突然之间就不存在了，门上贴着一个大红标签，取消抵押赎回权，银行拥有，滚出去，就像一个红字。你大约多大？我11岁。我爸爸总是工作，不工作，他有一份工作，他没有工作，他有一年好年，一年坏年。我记得有一年我们得到了一辆漂亮的新车，然后第二年我们卖掉了那辆车，换了一辆非常旧的车，然后有一年我们安装了一个内置游泳池
which was fantastic. The next year I remember my mother saying we couldn't afford the chemicals to swim so it turned out to be this pond of mosquitoes. Everything you're saying is exactly painting, breaking bad, chemicals. So that didn't drive you to study a career that is a bit more of a meritocracy as opposed to something that is left up to the decision of a sometimes unpredictable audience? Yeah, it did. Well my dad was gone, I didn't see him for at least 10, 11 years.
这太棒了。第二年我记得我母亲说我们买不起游泳的化学品，所以它变成了一个蚊子池。你说的每一句话都在准确地描绘《绝命毒师》，化学品。所以这没有驱使你去学习一个更像精英管理制度的职业，而不是留给有时不可预测的观众决定的职业吗？是的，确实。好吧，我爸爸走了，我至少有10、11年没见到他。
And so with that vacuum I kind of got attached to the idea of law enforcement because in those days, I don't know if you're old enough to remember, I'm older than all of you, but they used to have career days at high schools and they used to take over the gym and have military and firemen and the gas company and everybody represented and one of those was the LAPD and so I thought, wow, that's an image of a masculine man and so that looks like the right thing to do and they're in control. So I started kind of wondering about that and I became a police explorer and I did really well out of 116, 16 year olds all throughout Los Angeles, I graduated first in the class.
所以在那片空白中，我有点迷上了执法部门的想法，因为在那些日子里，我不知道你是否老到记得，我比你们所有人都老，但他们过去在高中举办职业日，他们过去接管体育馆，有军队、消防员、天然气公司和每个人代表，其中之一是洛杉矶警察局，所以我心想，哇，那是一个阳刚男人的形象，所以这看起来是正确的事情，而且他们有控制权。所以我开始有点好奇，我成了一名警察探险家，我做得非常好，在洛杉矶所有116名16岁少年中，我以第一名的成绩毕业。
So that told me, well, this is what you should do then, very pragmatic. So I got involved in it and I went to Valley Junior College to start studying it because we had no money and then I was going to transfer to UCLA with this police science degree and then go into the LAPD, that was my whole plan. Second year of Valley College, my counselor says, you need some elective courses. So I took, oh, acting, I did some of that when I was a kid, my dad was an actor and I did a couple of commercials and things like that. That sounds like fun, let's do that.
所以这告诉我，好吧，那你应该做这个，非常务实。所以我参与其中，我去了山谷初级学院开始学习它，因为我们没钱，然后我打算带着这个警察科学学位转学到加州大学洛杉矶分校，然后进入洛杉矶警察局，那是我的整个计划。山谷学院的第二年，我的辅导员说，你需要一些选修课。所以我选了，哦，表演，我小时候做过一些，我爸爸是演员，我做过几个广告之类的东西。这听起来很有趣，我们做那个吧。
So the first class I got into was a black box theater and the teacher who was over this whole thing and we're teaching these young kids. So he's handing out these scenes, you two read this and depending on who you were standing next to, that's who you're reading partner with, you two read this, you two read this, you two read this, go. And I looked down at the page, very nervous and it said, a couple is making out on a park bench. Oh my God, I looked up and I saw the girl I was supposed to read with and she was really
所以我进入的第一个班是一个黑匣子剧院，老师负责这一切，我们正在教这些年轻人。所以他分发这些场景，你们两个读这个，根据你站在谁旁边，那就是你的阅读伙伴，你们两个读这个，你们两个读这个，你们两个读这个，开始。我低头看着页面，非常紧张，上面写着，一对情侣在公园长椅上亲热。哦，天哪，我抬头看了看我应该一起读的女孩，她真的很
cute and I thought, oh my God, oh my God, oh my God, I'm 19 years old. If you tell me that's your wife, I'm going to freak out. It's not my wife. It's your wife, Jason. What? It's your wife. We'll be right back after these messages. She was amazing.
可爱，我想，哦，天哪，哦，天哪，哦，天哪，我19岁。如果你告诉我那是你妻子，我会吓坏的。那不是我妻子。那是你妻子，Jason。什么？那是你妻子。广告后我们马上回来。她太棒了。
Oh, she was amazing. I agree too. Guys. By the way, it should be noted that Jason's so nervous, he has career day on the set of Ozark once a week. I mean, this is how nervous he is, okay? I don't trust employment in this business. Wait, Brian, I want to know like family questions.
哦，她太棒了。我也同意。伙计们。顺便说一句，应该指出的是，Jason太紧张了，他每周在《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）片场都有职业日。我的意思是，他就是这么紧张，好吗？我不信任这个行业的就业。等等，布莱恩，我想知道像家庭问题。
So how did your mom raise you? Where did your dad go when you guys finally reconnected? What was that like? It's kind of sad. My mom started drinking and married four times and had numerous boyfriends. She was kind of like Blanche de Bois and put all her attention and effort and energy into the attention of men. And my dad remarried and went off and, I don't know, they were drinking a lot and probably
那么你妈妈是怎么抚养你的？当你和你们最终重新联系时，你爸爸去哪儿了？那是什么感觉？有点悲伤。我妈妈开始喝酒，结了四次婚，有无数男朋友。她有点像布兰奇·杜波依斯（Blanche de Bois），把她所有的注意力和努力和精力都放在了男人的关注上。我爸爸再婚了，离开了，我不知道，他们喝了很多酒，可能
doing some drugs and it was very unstable. So we just stayed away for a long time. And you were with your grandparents at this time? I was with my grandparents for a year. Then I went back and my brother and I lived with our mother again, but there was bad influence. And so by the time I was 16, I was pretty much on my own and trying to figure things out. I mean, the obvious question is why are you not, you know, holding up liquor stores right
吸了一些毒品，非常不稳定。所以我们很长一段时间都远离了。那时候你和祖父母在一起？我和祖父母住了一年。然后我回去了，我和哥哥又和母亲住在一起，但有坏影响。所以到我16岁时，我基本上是靠自己，试图弄清楚事情。我的意思是，显而易见的问题是为什么你现在没有，你知道，抢劫酒类商店
now or incarcerated or, I mean, why are you so high functioning? Because I'm out on parole. Why are you so balanced? You know, you strike me as a very kind man that's probably a really decent onset and probably a great family man yourself. I mean, is it just because you had an opposite model to look at and basically I'm just going to go left where everything else went right? Yeah, that's it.
或者被监禁，或者，我的意思是，为什么你功能这么高？因为我还在假释中。为什么你这么平衡？你知道，你给我的印象是一个非常善良的人，在片场可能是一个真正体面的人，可能你自己也是一个伟大的顾家男人。我的意思是，是因为你有一个相反的榜样可以看，基本上我只是要向左走，而其他一切都向右走吗？是的，就是这样。
It's like, okay, so that example didn't work and neither did that one. So don't do either one of those things. And you know, it's not the thing I would wish on anyone else and I wouldn't give that to my daughter. I've been married now for 31 years and we have a 27 year old daughter and life is good. And yeah, Jace, what you said is right is like you learn from your parents, hopefully it's good things and sometimes it's the opposite of that and so you have to just kind of forge your own way.
就像，好吧，那个例子没用，那个也没用。所以不要做那两件事中的任何一件。而且你知道，这不是我希望别人经历的事情，我也不会把它给我的女儿。我已经结婚31年了，我们有一个27岁的女儿，生活很好。而且是的，Jace，你说的对，就像你从父母那里学习，希望是好的事情，有时是相反的，所以你必须自己开辟自己的道路。
Can I just say as the sort of the outlier to these kinds of backgrounds, the three of you what I sort of what I've noticed is the three of you have stories that are not dissimilar in the sense that you had moments in your younger life. There was a lot of sort of trauma and familial trauma, et cetera. And all three of you guys and Brian, I'm just sort of just finding this out. All three of you guys kind of went the other way and I think that that's really interesting. Jason, you have gone since the day I've known you, you've always sort of sought out having a really firm, solid family life and in a home life and you settled down once you kind
我能说一下吗，作为这些背景的局外人，你们三个，我注意到的是，你们三个的故事并不相似，因为你们在年轻时都有过时刻。有很多创伤和家庭创伤等等。你们三个人，布莱恩，我只是刚发现这一点。你们三个人都走了另一条路，我觉得这真的很有趣。Jason，从我认识你的那天起，你一直都在寻求拥有一个非常坚定、稳固的家庭生活和家庭生活，当你到了某个年龄时，你安定下来，你寻求那个，Sean，你也是，你有一个非常——我在马戏团。而且你现在仍然是。公平地说。不，但你也有，你知道，而且你们三个人，看到三个在年轻时经历过很多逆境，处理着不一定适合11岁或12岁孩子的问题和议题的家伙，这很有趣。这需要承担很多。
of got to a certain age and you sought that out and Sean, you too, you have a very- I was in the circus. And you still sort of are. Let's be fair. No, but you also have, you know, and all three of you guys, it's funny to see three guys who had a lot of adversity at a young age dealing with problems and issues that aren't necessarily appropriate for 11-year-olds or 12-year-olds. It's a lot to take on.
而且也不要看轻自己，你知道，你会在一个你从来不需要折叠任何衣服的房子里长大。你现在知道怎么折叠衬衫和洗衣服了，对吧，在过去几年里。看看你，你现在可以装洗碗机了。因为总是由魔法师照顾，但重点是。每天早上你只是出现，这些是怎么折叠的，妈妈？那是，听着，让我告诉你一件事。
And don't sell yourself short either, you know, you will grow up in a house where you never had to fold any clothes at all. You know how to fold a shirt and run a load of wash now, right, in the last couple of years. Look at you, you can load a dishwasher now. Because it was always taken care of by the magic people, but the point is. Every morning you just show up, how did these get folded, mama? That is, listen, let me just tell you something.
我在寄宿学校时，我不想和你来回争论，Bateman。我对孩子大脑中发生的事情很着迷，这使得某些孩子变得清醒，并知道做出那些以负面形式呈现给他们的相反决定。为什么有些孩子像Jason说的那样向左走，而不是向右，反之亦然？为什么会这样？是的，因为它也涉及先天与后天的东西。你知道，如果是先天，那么我预先被设定为重复我父母经历的一些挑战。如果是后天，我也许也注定要走那些方向，因为这就是我得到的养育方式。现在，说了这么多，我从父母双方那里都得到了伟大的养育时刻。但谢天谢地，我有某种能力去挑选他们养育中最好的时刻，并消除一些他们今天可能会承认会做得有点不同的事情。但布莱恩，当你11岁时，这不是我们节目上的典型对话。
When I was at boarding school, I don't want to get into a back and forth with you, Bateman. I'm fascinated with what happens in a child's brain that makes certain kids turn on and become self-aware and know to make those opposite decisions that were presented to them in a negative form. Why do some kids go left like Jason said instead of right or vice versa? Why is that? Yeah, because it also speaks to the sort of nature versus nurture thing. You know, if it is nature, then I am pre-wired to repeat some of the same challenges that
这可能是我们有史以来最沉重的一次。天哪，Cranston。你真的毁了我们的氛围，布莱恩。我们一会儿要谈谈他的龙舌兰酒公司。是的，是的，是的。这会很有趣。顺便说一句，这是一个伟大的故事。所以他没有转向酒之类的东西。
my parents went through. And if it's nurture, I'm also perhaps predestined to go those directions because this is the kind of parenting that I'm getting. Now, having said all that, I had great moments of parenting from both of my parents. But thankfully, I had somewhat of an ability to kind of cherry-pick the best moments of their parenting and eliminate some of the things that they probably would admittedly do a little bit differently today. But Brian, when you were 11, this is not a typical conversation on our show.
他实际上开了一家酒公司。他就像，我要利用这一点。不，但当你11岁时，你知道吗？你意识到，嘿，该死，这很艰难，还是你当时只是随波逐流？好吧，你知道，那是一个艰难的年龄，11岁、12岁，当你刚开始向外看，认为你的基础已经完全设定好了。这是妈妈，爸爸。
This is probably about as heavy as we've ever been. Jesus Christ, Cranston. You really killed our vibe, Brian. We're going to get into his tequila company in a minute here. Yeah, yeah, yeah. This is going to be good. By the way, this is a great story. So he didn't turn to booze and stuff.
哦，天哪，现在外面有什么？突然之间，地毯被抽走了，你认为坚固的一切都不再坚固了。所以它让我崩溃了。我多年来变得内向，整个初中和高中。可能只有六个人记得我在高中时是谁，因为我只是贴在墙上。我没有任何自信。
He just actually started a booze company. He was like, I'm going to just monetize this. No, but when you were 11, did you know that? Did you recognize that, hey, shit, this is tough or did you just kind of roll with the punches at the time? Well, you know, that's a tough age, 11, 12, when you're just starting to look outward thinking that your foundation is all set. This is mom, dad.
我在任何事情上都没有安全网。所以我只是观察。现在，因此，我认为这实际上在以后的岁月里帮助了我，因为我在观察一切。对。但不知何故，你设法避免了酒，通常这会把人推向酒精，因为他们太保守，正在寻找一种打开自己的方式。是的。
Oh, God, now what's out there? And all of a sudden, the rug is pulled out and everything that you thought was solid is not. So it caved me in. I became an introvert for many years, all through middle school and high school. There's probably a half a dozen people that remember who I was in high school because I was just sucked up against the wall. I didn't have any confidence.
我认为这也是那种我不想要失控的感觉。保持控制有一种安全感。我认为这就是我所做的，因为我看到了我的父母。我正要说，你那样长大的恐惧是什么，你不想要什么？那让你变成了什么？因为一切都失控了，你的恐惧之一就是不被控制。这也看着人们做一些也许你不想做的事情，当你
I didn't have a safety net in anything. So I would just observe. Now, consequently, I think that actually helped me in later years because I was watching everything. Right. But somehow you managed to avoid the booze and usually that pushes people into alcohol because they're so reserved and looking for a way to open up. Yeah.
变老。我想知道这如何影响你对喜剧与戏剧的看法。如果你像我一样，你并没有真正对两者做出巨大的区分，因为我们俩通常都不会被选为那种真正的疯狂喜剧角色或真正的危险戏剧角色。我们有点扮演中间的那个家伙，要么被可怕的家伙追赶，要么对，你知道，像Will Arnett或Sean Hayes这样的白痴做出反应。对。
I think it's also that sense of I don't want to be out of control. There's a certain amount of safety in staying in control. And I think that's what did it for me is that I saw my parents. I was going to say, what is your fear from growing up like that, that you don't want to what? What did that make you become? Because of everything being out of control, one of your fears is not being in control. It's also looking at people doing something that perhaps you don't want to do when you
嘿，听着，我，首先，我为布莱恩对此感到冒犯，因为我记得《马尔科姆的一家》（Malcolm in the Middle）里有很多集，布莱恩是个该死的白痴。谢谢，Will。不客气，伙计。我支持你。真是个好节目。所以你真的在乎喜剧与戏剧，还是你只是在寻找包装的其他部分？
get older. I wonder how that affects like comedy versus drama for you. If you're like me, you don't really make a huge distinction between the two because neither one of us are usually cast as like the real crazy comedy guy or the real dangerous drama guy. We kind of play kind of the guy in the middle that's either getting chased by the scary guy or reacting to, you know, the idiot like Will Arnett or Sean Hayes. Right.
你知道，如果我做太多其中一种，我就在乎。我关心进入另一种，你知道，我不想被称为任何一种东西。我想不断挑战自己。我想不断尝试新事物，发现我是否擅长它。但至少，你知道，我只是不想被定型。所以当《马尔科姆的一家》七年后结束时，我被提供了两个试播集来扮演一个甜蜜愚蠢的爸爸。我立刻，当然，是拒绝，因为如果我直接进入别的东西，我会对自己产生衍生。你只是不能。天哪，那是危险的，对吧？因为就像在完美的情况下，你正在做的事情变得非常成功。但随之而来的是被定型为那个，因为现在那是一个非常高调的事情，就像《马尔科姆的一家》那样。嗨。但它们被展示了。
Hey, listen, I, first of all, I take offense for Brian on this because I remember there are plenty of episodes of Malcolm in the middle where Brian was a fucking idiot. Thank you, Will. You're welcome, man. I got your back. Such a good show. So do you really care about comedy versus drama or are you just kind of looking for the other parts of the package?
哦，天哪。但幸运的是，你与Vince Gilligan有预先存在的关系。所以他能够看穿这一点，并抛出一个《绝命毒师》。是的。这太不可思议了。你知道，我的《X档案》（X Files）那一集只是一个需要工作的演员去做了它。然后九年后，在《马尔科姆》结束后，我接到了这个电话。
You know, I care about it if I've been doing too much of one. I care about going into the other, you know, and I don't want to be known as any one thing. I want to keep challenging myself. I want to keep trying new things and discover if I'm any good at it. But at the very least, you know, I just don't want to be pigeonholed. So when Malcolm in the middle ended after seven years, I was offered two pilots to play a sweet goofy dad. And I immediately, of course, it was no because I would be derivative of myself if I went
而且Sean，这说明了运气因素，福克斯说，保持布景。我们可能会做《马尔科姆的一家》的第八季，每个人都说，是的，那太棒了。在四月，四月下旬和五月初，他们在预售会进行时打电话。他们说，不，我们有一个非常好的试播季。谢谢你们。你们做得很好。你们靠自己了。
right into something else. You just can't. God, that's the danger though, right? Because like in the perfect scenario, the thing that you're doing becomes a huge success. But with that comes being pigeonholed as that, because now that's a very high profile thing like Malcolm in the middle was. Hi. But they're shown.
所以我们以为在……哦，那太糟糕了。那个月晚些时候，我接到电话去见一个叫Vince Gilligan的人。你还记得他从《X档案》里来的吗？他想见你关于这个叫《绝命毒师》的新项目。我读了它，我想，哦，天哪，这太棒了。我见了他。他说，我想把奇普斯先生（Mr. Chips）变成疤面煞星（Scarface）。
Oh my goodness. But fortunately for you, you had a preexisting relationship with Vince Gilligan. So he was able to kind of look past that and throw a breaking badger away. Yeah. It was unbelievable. You know, my episode of X Files was just an actor needing a job and going out and doing it. And then nine years later, I get this call after Malcolm finished.
而且我认为你，你是做这件事的人。我知道AMC和索尼都说，等等，不，等等，等等，沃尔特·怀特（Walter White）不能是《马尔科姆的一家》里那个愚蠢的爸爸，求求你，求求你，让我们看看别人。让我们，你知道，他是我的拥护者，我需要那种好运，有人在我的角落里说，不，不，不，他是一个演员。那是他当时在做的。这就是，所以他复印了他写并制作的《X档案》那一集，寄给了索尼和AMC的人，说，看，这是我见到他的时候。
And Sean, this speaks to the luck factor, Fox said, keep the sets up. We might do an eighth season of Malcolm in the middle and everybody's like, yeah, that would be great. In April, late April and early May, they called when the up front are going on. They said, no, we had a very good pilot season. Thank you guys. You did well. And you're on your own.
所以现在你告诉我，你认为他能做到吗？哇。哇。那个节目的精髓在于，你知道，你开始时并不是你结束时的样子。你开始时是一个非常谦逊的、被动的、几乎是《马尔科姆的一家》类型的角色，所以那部分是一个巨大的契合。希望，我想他们确实看到了那可能是一个很好的平滑过渡点，并且
So we thought at the fur. Oh, that's too bad. Later that month, I get the call to go see a guy named Vince Gilligan. Do you remember him from X Files kind of? And he wants to see you about this new project called Breaking Bad. And I read it and I thought, oh my God, this is amazing. I met with him. He says, I want to turn Mr. Chips into Scarface.
因此你会是完美的。是的。现在，有趣的是运气因素在于，我们在07年2月和3月拍摄了试播集。如果我们得到了《马尔科姆的一家》的第八季，我就没有时间去拍摄那个试播集，别人就会。那不是很神奇吗。是的，你知道，听着，这不有趣吗，布莱恩正要说什么，只是切断
And I think you're, you're the guy to do it. And I know that AMC and Sony both said, wait, no, wait, wait, wait, Walter White can't be that goofy dad from Malcolm in the middle, please, please, let's see others. Let's, you know, and he was my champion and I needed that good fortune to have someone in my corner to say, no, no, no, he's an actor. That's what he was doing then. And this is what, and so he copied off his episode that he wrote and produced on X Files and sent it to the people at Sony and AMC and said, look, this is when I met him.
我们的嘉宾。好吧，不，我只是想说，这绝对是我的信念。我教条地相信这一点，在我们这个行业，没有一点运气点缀，职业生涯就无法完全实现。我完全同意。当然。但我正要说的是，这不有趣吗，当你开始因为你惊人的工作而获得认可，名声就降临到你身上时，你的
So now you tell me, do you think he can do that? Wow. Wow. The in on that show is that, you know, you don't start at the beginning of it as how you end in it. You start as a very unassuming sort of passive type of almost Malcolm in the middle type of character was so that part of it is a huge fit. And hopefully, I guess they did see that that might be a nice smooth transition point and
感觉就像，好吧，我不明白。我一直在这里做我的事情，看起来你周围的每个人都变了。我们都知道，大规模的认可总是一件好事，因为它有助于获得下一份工作。但当《绝命毒师》时，你的感觉是什么，因为你并没有因为《马尔科姆的一家》而不出名，但《绝命毒师》让你变得非常成功和出名。所以那是什么感觉？你觉得，哦，终于我得到了我一直在追求的东西？
therefore you would be perfect. Yeah. Now, what was interesting in the luck factor comes in is that we shot the pilot February and March of 07. Had we got that eighth season of Malcolm in the middle, I would not have been available to shoot that pilot and someone else would be. Isn't that amazing. Yeah, you know, listen, isn't it interesting, Brian was going to say something, just cut
还是你有点像试图不买评论家的账，无论多么正面或负面，只是保持你的头脑在游戏中？我想回到谈话的开始，我只是学会了运用我的能力去应用职业道德，只是低下头去工作。如果有人拍拍你的肩膀说，嘿，我们想给你一份工作，哦，太棒了。如果有人拍拍你的肩膀说，我们想提名你，哦，哇，真的吗？哦，那太棒了。
our guest. Well, no, I was just going to say that it is absolutely my belief. I dogmatically believe this, that a career in our business cannot be fully realized without a healthy dose of luck sprinkled throughout. I totally agree. For sure. But what I was going to say, isn't it kind of interesting that when you start getting recognition for your amazing work and, and fame kind of just happens upon you, you're
你永远，永远不要因为你认为它会让你获得提名而去找工作。是的，Jason。好吧，不，Sean也是。现在，布莱恩，这是我必须向你承认的另一件事，现在我们坐着或互相交谈。我真的，真的对《绝命毒师》游戏很晚。这些年来，我们在行业中擦肩而过。
feeling is like, well, I don't understand it. I've always been here doing my thing and it seems like everyone around you kind of changes. And we all know that recognition on a wide scale is always a good thing because it helps getting your next gig. But what was your feeling like when breaking bad because you weren't not famous because of Malcolm in the middle, but breaking bad just made you hugely successful and famous. So what was that feeling like? Did you feel like, oh, finally I got the thing that I've been after?
我一直很善良，我一直把你视为业内最有才华的人之一。有人很有趣。你没看过《绝命毒师》。你必须看它。所以我大概一年前，两年前才看了它。所以现在再次见到你，对我来说真的很疯狂。哦，那很好。
Or were you kind of like trying not to buy into the critics, no matter how positive or negative and just kind of keep your head in the game? I think getting back to the beginning of the conversation, I just learned to take my ability to apply the work ethic, just keep your head down and go to work. If someone taps you on the shoulder and says, hey, we want to give you a job, oh, great. If someone taps you on the shoulder and says, we want to nominate you for some, oh, wow, really? Oh, that's fantastic.
因为我当时想，天哪。所以它在我脑海中比——笔记来了，布莱恩。笔记来了。笔记来了。你可以被锁定，Sean。如果图片被锁定了。绝对锁定了。
You never, ever look to take a job because you think it's going to get you nominated for something. Yeah, Jason. Well, no, with Sean as well. And now, Brian, this is the other thing I have to admit to you now that we're sitting or talking to each other. I was really, really late to the breaking bad game. And we've met each other passing through the business over the years.
小事。没什么大不了的。老实说，老实说，这只是一个小调整。我实际上想知道，当你制作那个节目时，你是否感受到了那种讲故事的满足感？因为剧本太强了。我的意思是，表演太棒了。但你是否感觉到那种，每次你拿到剧本时，就像，是的，是的。
I've always been so kind and I've always looked up to you as one of the most talented people in the business. And somebody's funny. You haven't seen Breaking Bad. You've got to see it. So I just watched it like a year ago, two years ago. And so this is really kind of crazy for me to meet, to see you right now again. Oh, that's good.
正如我们所知，这一切都取决于剧本的力量。如果它在那里，那么你可以提升它并真正拥抱它。但如果它不在那里，你做不了太多。那个试播剧本很大胆。他想要做什么。他告诉我，他说，我想把主角从好人变成坏人。我想，那从来没做过。是的。
Because I was like, holy shit. So it's much fresher in my mind than- Here come the notes, though, Brian. Here come the notes. Here come the notes. You can be locked, Sean. If the picture's locked. Definitely locked.
即使托尼·索普拉诺（Tony Soprano）是他自己，维克·麦基（Vic Mackey）和所有这些在我之前出现的角色，但真正改变一个角色。但在不知道你们会得到多少季的情况下，是否有关于你将如何根据不知道它是三季还是六季来校准那个弧线的对话，以便让那个角色去的地方着陆，他真的不知道他能把音调放在什么角度，对吧？现在，Vince Gilligan的焦虑的好处是，他说，好吧，我不知道他们是否会让我做这个，但我们会试一试。
Little thing. It's not a big deal. Honestly, honestly, it's just a slight adjustment. I actually want to know, when you were making that show, did you feel that storytelling kind of that satisfaction making it? Because the writing was so strong. I mean, the performances were off the hook. But did you feel that sense of like, every time you got a script going like, yes, yeah.
他们可能会在前六集内取消我们。我知道他们会。他们不会让我们做我想做的事，但管他呢，我们会试一试。演员是那些有焦虑和不安全感的人。是的。你知道，我的意思是，人们总是问我们，你知道你的节目，《威尔与格蕾丝》（Will and Grace）或《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）吗？
As we know, it's all about the strength of the writing. If it's there, then you can elevate that and really embrace it. But if it's not there, there's not much you can do. That pilot script was audacious. He's what he wanted to do. He told me, he said, I want to change the lead character from a good guy to a bad guy. And I thought, that's never been done. Yeah.
你知道那会成为热门吗？当然我们不知道。你只是对某事做出反应。你回应剧本和角色，你尽你最大的努力，你希望。然后它变成了它变成的样子。就像，哦，天哪。是的。布莱恩，当然我必须问那个股票问题，因为我们正在谈论那个
Even Tony Soprano was who he was and Vic Mackey and all these characters I came before, but to actually change a character. But without knowing how many seasons you guys were going to get, were there conversations with Vince about how you were going to calibrate that arc based on not knowing whether it was going to be a three-season arc or a six-season arc for it to land the plane where that character goes, he didn't really know what kind of angle he could put the pitch at, right? Now, that's the good thing about Vince Gilligan's anxiety is that he said, well, I don't know if they're going to let me do this, but we'll just give it a try.
真正让你职业生涯突飞猛进的事情。我很抱歉问它，但你是否曾经感到有必要匹配它或超越它？我的意思是，显然你可能忽略了它，因为你是一个伟大的人，你是一个超级聪明的人，你的头脑在游戏中，你是一个伟大的演员。但你内心是否有任何一部分说，哦，天哪，下一份工作，它至少必须像《绝命毒师》一样大。你知道，当我们要在2013年结束我们的制作时，我肯定有那种感觉。
They'll probably cancel us within the first six episodes. I know they will. They're not going to let us do what I want to do, but what the hell, we'll just give it a try. And the actors are the ones with the anxiety and insecure. Yeah. You know, I mean, people always ask us, did you know your show, Will and Gray's are arrested or Ozone?
我想，哦，门槛太高了，我永远无法找到，它必须是某种东西。我被提供了电影《哥斯拉》（Godzilla），我拒绝了。你没想过你能扮演一只蜥蜴吗？我认为你有不可思议的范围，布莱恩。是的。你要对自己好一点。是的。我说，我不知道，那行不通。
Did you know that was going to be a hit? And of course we don't. You just react to something. You respond to the writing and the character and you give it your best shot and you hope. And then it turned out to be the way it turned out. And it's like, oh my God. Yeah. Brian, of course I have to ask the stock question because we're talking about the thing that
我拒绝了两次。然后我开始思考它，我意识到，好吧，等一下，我对此太势利了吗？这根本不是《绝命毒师》的领域。这是一个完全不同的类型。我小时候很喜欢《哥斯拉》。这是一个很好的角色，你知道吗，也许这正是你应该做的，一些如此不同的事情，以至于它不能以同样的方式衡量。
really just catapulted your career. And I'm sorry for asking it, but do you ever feel a sense of having to match it or top it? I mean, obviously you probably ignore that because you're a great person and you're a super smart person and your head is in the game and you're a great actor. But does any part of you inside just go, oh my God, this next job, it has to be as big as Breaking Bad at least. You know, when we were about to close out our production in 2013, I had that for sure.
确实让你的事业突飞猛进。我很抱歉问这个问题，但你是否曾感到必须去匹配或超越它？我的意思是，显然你可能会忽略这一点，因为你是一个很棒的人，一个超级聪明的人，你专注于工作，而且你是一位伟大的演员。但你内心深处有没有一部分会想，天哪，下一份工作至少得和《绝命毒师》一样大。你知道，当我们在2013年即将结束制作时，我肯定有过这种感觉。
I thought, oh, the bar is so high, I'll never be able to find, it's got to be something. And I was offered the movie Godzilla and I turned it down. You didn't think you could play a lizard? I think you've got an incredible range, Brian. Yes. You're going to be nicer to yourself. Yeah. And I said, I don't know, that's not going to work.
我想，哦，门槛太高了，我永远也找不到，它必须得是什么样的。当时有人邀请我拍电影《哥斯拉》，我拒绝了。你觉得你演不了蜥蜴？我觉得你的戏路非常广，布莱恩。是的。你要对自己好一点。是的。我说，我不知道，那行不通。
And I turned it down twice. And then I started thinking about it and I realized, well, wait a minute, am I being snooty about this? This is not in nowhere the same realm as a Breaking Bad. It's a completely different genre. And I loved Godzilla when I was a kid. And this is a good role and you know what, maybe that's exactly what I should do is something so different that it can't be really measured in the same way.
我拒绝了两次。然后我开始思考，我意识到，等等，我是不是太自命不凡了？这和《绝命毒师》根本不是同一个领域。这是一个完全不同的类型。我小时候很喜欢《哥斯拉》。这是一个很好的角色，你知道吗，也许我应该做的正是那种完全不同的事情，以至于它无法以同样的方式被衡量。
And plus those two passes taught you a little something about negotiating too. A little bit. A little bit a little hard to get. Yeah. The feet. And it filled a lot of gaps. It filled a lot of gaps. Sure it did.
而且那两次试镜也让你学到了一些关于谈判的技巧。一点点。有点难搞。对，就是脚。而且它填补了很多空白。它填补了很多空白。当然是这样。
Brian, how do you cope with downtime? Are you always like, I got to work, I got to work? You know, that syndrome of saying, yes, as a beginning actor, it's hard to turn that bus around. So just naturally, I love to act. It's really a passion of mine. I've been doing it for 40 years and it's so much fun. So when it stops being fun is when I retire.
布莱恩，你是怎么应对空窗期的？你总是觉得，我得工作，我得工作吗？你知道，作为一名刚入行的演员，那种“必须说好”的综合症很难摆脱。所以很自然地，我热爱表演。这确实是我的热情所在。我已经干了40年了，这真的很有趣。所以当它不再有趣的时候，就是我退休的时候。
Yeah. Brian, you've had good luck because, and also because you're very talented, but I feel the same way, I'm very not precious about doing stuff. And I've made a ton of what could from the outside be looked at as blunders, but I also don't give a shit because in the world, life is so long and so, and they're all just experiences. And I'm not, I don't feel worse as a person today because I've done some things that didn't go right. I never, I never set out to do things that were crappy.
是啊。布莱恩，你很幸运，因为你非常有才华，但我也有同感，我对做事情一点也不矫情。我做过很多在外人看来可能是失误的事情，但我根本不在乎，因为人生很长，这些都只是经历。我今天并没有因为做了一些不顺利的事情而觉得自己更差劲。我从来没有打算把事情搞砸。
I think you also have a great deal of faith that you're not going to suck in it. The product might be something less than what you would want it to be. But I think we all know that we don't have control over four corners of a product. You can only do your part as well as you can. And you truly, it is to me that you look at the rest of the package, who else is involved? What's it kind of going for? And the actual part itself or the prospects of success or financial growth is sort of second to what the whole thing is going to be or what you hope it can be.
我觉得你也有很大的信念，相信自己不会搞砸。产品本身可能不如你预期的那么好。但我想我们都知道，我们无法控制产品的方方面面。你只能尽力做好你自己的那部分。对我来说，你确实会去关注整个项目的其他部分，还有谁参与？它大概是什么样的？而角色本身，或者成功的机会、经济收益，其实都排在整个项目最终会呈现出什么样子，或者你希望它能成为什么样子之后。
Is that, is that something that, is that how you kind of factor things, Brian, or is it, is it more about the part itself? It's about the money. Yeah. Good for you. Good for you. Finally. No.
布莱恩，你是这样考虑问题的吗？还是说你更看重角色本身？是关于钱的。是啊。为你高兴。为你高兴。终于。不。
The moment that I stopped thinking about money is the moment I've started making more than I ever thought I would in my life. And it's never really been about that. As a matter of fact, I had an epiphany in one of the rounds being a working actor all through the days of those shows in the 80s. I was doing every guest star on every show, Murder She Wrote and Matlock and this and that and Gyps and, you know, you name it and all that stuff. And I kept going into an audition thinking I was there to get a job.
当我不再考虑钱的那一刻，就是我开始赚到比我这辈子想象中更多的钱的时候。其实这从来都不是重点。事实上，在80年代那些剧集拍摄期间，作为一名职业演员，我有过一次顿悟。我当时在每一部剧里都客串，比如《女作家与谋杀案》、《马特洛克》等等，你能想到的那些剧。我当时去试镜时，总觉得我是去“找工作”的。
And then I finally realized, oh, this is the wrong way to go in. You have to go in to do a job, not to get a job. So if you walk into an office and you don't want anything from them, you're there to give them something, your energy completely changes, you're, you're coming in there with confidence and you leave them with your work, with, you worked on it and you did the audition and you walk away. And from that point on, I've never stopped working. That's the best advice.
后来我终于意识到，哦，这种心态不对。你应该去“做工作”，而不是去“找工作”。所以如果你走进办公室时，不求他们什么，而是去给他们提供点什么，你的能量就会完全改变。你带着自信走进去，留下你的作品，你努力准备了，完成了试镜，然后离开。从那以后，我就再也没停下工作。这是最好的建议。
Yeah. That is great advice for young actors because I battled that a ton. You know, you, you try to find that, that healthy indifference walking into, to a job. But man, it's so hard when you're somewhat savvy about what the prospects of this particular project could be, it's, it's tough to turn that off. Did you feel that pressure, Jason, when you were younger, like because you did, you were a big breadwinner for your family, did that ever come into it while you were going into an audition?
是啊。这对年轻演员来说真是个好建议，因为我以前也为此挣扎过很多。你知道，你试图在去面试时找到那种健康的冷漠感。但是，伙计，当你对这个特定项目的前景有所了解时，真的很难做到这一点。杰森，你年轻时有这种压力吗？因为你当时是家里的顶梁柱，你在去试镜时会想到这些吗？
Yeah. Yeah. And I find that the thing that, that Brian's talking about where it's this, I'm just going to prepare this scene, this audition and just kind of do it the way I want to do it. And if they like that, then they can have that, but I'm not going to try to, to hit this invisible target and try to guess what they want because I so badly need the job. That's, that's a, it's a, it's a, it's very lucky if you can get to that place that Brian is talking about.
会，会。我发现布莱恩说的那个状态，就是“我只是准备好这场戏，这场试镜，然后按我想的方式去演”。如果他们喜欢，那他们就拿去；但我不会试图去击中那个看不见的目标，去猜测他们想要什么，因为我太需要这份工作了。如果你能达到布莱恩所说的那个境界，那真是非常幸运。
And, you know, it's, it's not too dissimilar from, you know, growing up and trying to, you know, attract somebody to you, you know, in school, like, you know, if you can find that sort of that sexy indifference and, you know, that kind of playing hard to get, even if it's not manipulative, if it's an, if it's sincere indifference, where you don't need this relationship, then you just become really attractive. But that's a tough line to, because then that's a manufactured indifference. Well, no, I mean, I think, that's why I'm obsessed with Jason Bateman. He won't let me in.
而且，这和你成长过程中试图吸引某人注意没什么两样，比如在学校里，如果你能找到那种性感的冷漠感，那种欲擒故纵，即使不是操纵，如果是真诚的冷漠，你不依赖这段关系，那你就会变得非常有吸引力。但这很难把握，因为那可能会变成一种刻意的冷漠。好吧，不，我的意思是，这就是为什么我迷恋杰森·贝特曼。他不让我靠近。
If you've got your room clean upstairs, right? If you've, if you've got your stuff together, then you are somewhat self-reliant in a lot of things in life. Right. And you, you kind of right size a lot of things and, and, and you don't press. I, at least that, that's my own thing. I try to apply that to as much as I can. He's the man with manufactured indifference.
如果你把楼上的房间打扫干净了，对吧？如果你把自己的事情处理好了，那么你在生活中很多事情上都是自立的。对吧？你会把很多事情调整到合适的状态，而且你不会强求。至少，这是我自己的做法。我尽量把它应用到我能做到的尽可能多的事情上。他就是那个拥有刻意冷漠感的人。
He's welcome. Jason Bateman. Brian, because you're such a good, wonderful soul and you're kind and you're gentle and you are just an all around great guy and everybody knows this about you in the business. And on top of that, you're extraordinarily talented. I want to know what makes you mad. What makes, what pisses you off at work or just in life with people? Well, I, I don't, you know, if, if you are the number one on the call sheet, I, I try
不客气。杰森·贝特曼。布莱恩，因为你是一个如此美好、善良、温柔的人，是一个全方位的好人，圈子里的人都知道这一点。而且最重要的是，你非常有才华。我想知道什么会让你生气？在工作中或者生活中，什么事情会让你火大？嗯，我，你知道，如果你是通告单上的第一位，我尽量
to set a tone. I take out my cast, whether I'm doing a play or doing a film or whatever. And I say, all right, here's, here's what I think. I think we're the luckiest bastards in the world. So I think that we should be on time and I think we should all be prepared and come in with ideas and let's be able to feel free to have artistic frustration, but let's leave all the drama out of it. Let's go.
去定下基调。我会带我的演员们出去，无论是在排戏还是拍电影。我会说，好吧，我的想法是这样的。我觉得我们是世界上最幸运的混蛋。所以我认为我们应该准时，我们都应该做好准备，带着想法来，我们可以自由地表达艺术上的挫折感，但让我们把所有的戏剧性冲突都抛开。开始吧。
Let's have fun. Let's go to work and go home. Yeah. And if we can do that, that's great. I get in my car with the other cast man and be like, this fucking guy with this fucking rule. That's it. And it's like, know your stuff and, you know, know your work and be kind, be respectful.
让我们玩得开心。让我们去工作，然后回家。是啊。如果我们能做到这一点，那就太棒了。我和其他演员上车时会想，这个该死的家伙，还有这些该死的规矩。就是这样。就像是，了解你的东西，了解你的工作，保持友善，保持尊重。
And I'm truly mad. So how do you deal with somebody who isn't that? Well, I pull them aside. And I say, what, you know, basically, what's the problem? Is there a problem? Can I help you with solving this as a reason that you're not on time? God, you're a good guy. You're such a good guy.
我是真的生气了。那你怎么处理那些不这样的人呢？嗯，我会把他们拉到一边。然后我会说，基本上，问题是什么？有什么问题吗？我能帮你解决吗？是因为什么原因你没准时吗？天哪，你真是个好人。你真是个好人。
Can I talk to you for a second? Just don't. Are you pulling me aside? Yeah. Yeah. What do you usually find that those people are usually afflicted with a lack of experience, a sense of entitlement, insecurity, it's usually fear, right? I've found that bad behavior usually comes from people that just don't, don't feel comfortable
我能跟你谈谈吗？别这样。你是在把我拉到一边吗？是啊。是啊。你通常发现那些人是因为缺乏经验、有特权感、不安全感，通常是恐惧，对吧？我发现糟糕的行为通常来自那些感到不舒服的人。
at all. And then, and then you, you probably take that on as, as number one and you make them feel a bit better. Yeah. Well, it's both, you know, it's the right thing to do as a, as a person, but it's also the right thing to do for your production. Yeah. If incrementally, if every guest star comes onto your show and they feel comfortable, they're
然后，你可能作为第一位演员承担起这个责任，让他们感觉好一点。是啊。嗯，两者都有，你知道，作为一个人，这是正确的事情，但对你的制作来说，这也是正确的事情。是啊。如果每一个客串明星来到你的剧组，他们都感到舒适，他们
going to perform better. And if they perform better, the show is going to be better and everything is lifted. Everybody has a better time. So, you know, that thing you talk about that kind of leadership on, on set and that kind of, there are so much I learned a lot from this guy from Jason when we were doing arrested and guys let him finish early on season one. This is true story. I don't know if you remember this and you did it very sort of gently.
就会表现得更好。如果他们表现得更好，节目就会更好，一切都会提升。每个人都会过得更开心。所以，你谈到的那种片场领导力，我从杰森身上学到了很多，当时我们在拍《发展受阻》，第一季的时候，伙计们让他早点收工。这是真实的故事。我不知道你还记不记得，你做得非常温和。
I remember thinking, I had nowhere to go, but I remember being like, what's saying to the 80, first 80, like, what time are we wrapping tonight? You know, the worst thing you can do. And, and Jason, Jason, I were in a scene and he looked at me and he goes, we got you for the whole day, right? And, and it really, and it really, it really affected me and put me in my place and I understood in that moment, I got all of it. I got the subtlety and the not so subtlety of it and it changed the way my entire behavior
我记得当时我想，我没地方可去，但我记得当时就像是，对80个人说，我们今晚几点收工？你知道，这是你能做的最糟糕的事情。然后，杰森，我和杰森当时在拍一场戏，他看着我说，我们今天一整天都有你的档期，对吧？这真的，真的影响了我，让我认清了自己的位置，那一刻我全明白了。我明白了其中的微妙之处，甚至是不那么微妙之处，它永远改变了我在片场的行为方式。
on sets forever. I was influenced by Tom Hanks, Jim Garner, Dick Van Dyke, these, these people who, especially Tom, I've done several, four different projects with him and, and his comportment is just right where you want it to be. He's fun. He keeps it light. He absolutely knows his stuff and everybody coming in better as well. You know, so you're playing, but you're playing within the context of the show.
我受到了汤姆·汉克斯、吉姆·加纳、迪克·范·戴克这些人的影响，尤其是汤姆，我和他合作过四个不同的项目，他的举止恰到好处。他很有趣。他让气氛保持轻松。他绝对了解他的工作，而且让每个进来的人也表现得更好。所以，你在表演，但你是在节目的背景下表演。
And then he wraps early, everybody goes home and it's like, that was a fun day. I can't wait for tomorrow. Yeah. I've always told him I want to get a bracelet made since WWTHD. What would Tom Hanks do? Yeah. Yeah. It would fix a lot.
然后他早早收工，每个人都回家了，感觉就像，那真是愉快的一天。我迫不及待想迎接明天了。是啊。我一直跟他说我想做一个手环，上面写着WWTHD。汤姆·汉克斯会怎么做？是啊。是啊。那能解决很多问题。
Brian, what would people be most shocked to learn that you're great at? I put in my 10,000 hours, thank you to Malcolm Gladwell, of loading the dishwasher. I am an excellent loader of a dishwasher. You know, I do literally struggle with that. I don't know what to do with the bowls because the bowls will take up a great deal of space unnecessarily. And if you stack them too much, you're not going to get a lot of water through there to clean that up.
布莱恩，人们最惊讶于你擅长什么？我投入了1万个小时，感谢马尔科姆·格拉德威尔，在装洗碗机上。我是一个装洗碗机的高手。你知道，我确实在为碗的事情发愁，因为碗会不必要地占用大量空间。如果你堆得太多，水就流不进去，洗不干净。
So I'm tempted sometimes to put it up on the, on the cup rack, but then there's not enough room for that. How do you fight that temptation? Yeah. I just, so at that point, I just start breaking them, you know, you don't need to clean ones that are broken. Whoa. That's a little aggressive.
所以我有时很想把它放在杯架上，但那样就没有足够的空间放杯子了。你怎么克服这种诱惑？是啊。到了那个时候，我就开始把它们弄碎，你知道，碎了的就不需要洗了。哇。这有点激进。
Yeah. So I just break them. And then, and then my wife says, forget it, you can't load the dishwasher anymore. And I say, okay. Well, that was your plan. Yeah. Yeah. The whole, oh, petulant really quick.
是啊。所以我只是把它们弄碎。然后，我妻子说，算了，你以后别装洗碗机了。我说，好吧。嗯，那是你的计划。是啊。是啊。整个过程，哦，真是太任性了。
Evil genius. Yeah. What's a dishwasher? Very nice. So Brian, so no, no sports, no, you're not a closet opera singer or painter, no, no, no. Wow. Green thumb.
邪恶天才。是啊。什么是洗碗机？非常好。所以布莱恩，没有运动，你不是那种隐藏的歌剧歌手或画家，没有，没有，没有。哇。园艺能手。
I have been known to play the drums a little bit. Oh, really? I used to run marathons. Really? Wow. Yep. I was a marathon runner. Did you ever do the Boston?
我以前还会打一点鼓。哦，真的吗？我以前跑马拉松。真的吗？哇。是的。我曾经是一名马拉松选手。你跑过波士顿马拉松吗？
Cause you got to do a sub four. I never did Boston. You got to do sub four hour time, right? To get in there. Yeah. And I did all four of my registered times were all under four hours. No way. For you.
因为你得跑进4小时以内。我从没跑过波士顿。你得跑进4小时以内，对吧？才能进去。是啊。我所有四次注册的成绩都在4小时以内。不会吧。为你。
Of course. Now, wait, why, why did you, why did you stop? Did your trick knee act up or something? Cause it's hard. No. I'll tell you why I did it. I was on a soap opera in 1984. Which one?
当然。等等，为什么，为什么你停下来了？是因为你的膝盖旧伤复发了吗？因为这很难。不。我告诉你为什么。我1984年拍过一部肥皂剧。哪一部？
You do have an incredible jawline. Loving. Oh, yes. There's a show called Loving on ABC and I was working in New York and I was one of the young knuckleheads, you know, in the soap opera days, it was like you're either a good person or a bad person. Right. And I was a good person and I was on for two years and lo and behold, right before the
你的下颌线确实令人难以置信。Loving。哦，是的。ABC有一部剧叫《Loving》，我在纽约工作，我是那些年轻的笨蛋之一，你知道，在肥皂剧时代，你要么是个好人，要么是个坏人。对吧。我是个好人，我演了两年，结果就在年底之前，
end of the year, I was thinking, well, this has been a great two years, but I think I'm going to move on and do something else and I get called in the office and they fire me. Wow. It's like they didn't pick up my contract. And of course it's like someone dumping you, right? That you know you were going to dump and then they get a chance to do it first. You go, no, no, no, no, wait, wait, wait, wait, no, we can make this work. You can't fire me.
我心想，这两年过得真棒，但我打算继续前进，做点别的事情，结果我被叫进办公室，他们解雇了我。哇。就像他们没续签我的合同。当然，这就像有人甩了你，对吧？你知道你本来打算甩掉对方，结果他们先下手为强。你会说，不，不，不，不，等等，等等，等等，我们可以解决这个问题。你不能解雇我。
I quit. So I, I was, I was so despondent and, and felt so sorry for myself. And a day, that was on a Friday and then Saturday moped around and on a Sunday, I said, get out of this, grab a bunch of film, of course, real film in those days. And I grabbed my camera, my camera bag and I said, I'm going to go out and I'm just going to shoot all day long and just be, do something creative. And I walk into Central Park and I go, what's all this is, oh my God, is that, it's that marathon.
我辞职。所以我当时非常沮丧，为自己感到难过。那是周五，周六我无所事事，周日我说，走开，拿上一堆胶卷，当然是那个年代真正的胶卷。我拿上相机和相机包，我说，我要出去，我要拍一整天，做点有创意的事情。我走进中央公园，我说，这是什么，天哪，是那个马拉松。
I'm not going to be able to take pictures. And I said, well, the first picture I took was of these two extremely fat cops in uniform. And they're- You're like what I could have been. Yes. Their bellies were touching each other, but they were six feet apart. And with a sign, runners this way, runners that way, and I thought, oh, that's a pretty good picture.
我没法拍照了。我说，我拍的第一张照片是两个穿着制服的超级胖警察。他们——你就像我可能成为的样子。是的。他们的肚子碰在一起，但他们其实隔了六英尺远。旁边有个牌子，写着“跑者这边，跑者那边”，我想，哦，那是一张不错的照片。
So I started taking pictures and I stayed there for five and a half hours. And I watched this and I'm watching the sea of humanity run. I'm at the finish line at Tavern on the Green. And I'm watching it. And I said, I heard myself say, I could never do this. And then I stopped and I went, why couldn't I do that? I don't know if I can do that. Why would I say I can't do it the next year I was in that race?
所以我开始拍照，我在那儿待了五个半小时。我看着这一切，看着那片人类的海洋奔跑。我在Tavern on the Green的终点线。我看着它。我听到自己说，我永远做不到这一点。然后我停下来，心想，为什么我做不到？我不知道我能不能做到。我为什么要说我做不到？第二年我就参加了那场比赛。
Wow. Good for you. Wow. Well, I think, had I not been fired, it wouldn't have happened. Yeah. Brian, have you always had that in you, because this kind of goes back to what we started with, which is you were dealt kind of a crappy hand and you made the most of it. And there's another example.
哇。为你高兴。哇。嗯，我想，如果我没被解雇，这一切就不会发生。是啊。布莱恩，你一直都有这种特质吗？因为这回到了我们开始的话题，就是你拿到了一手烂牌，但你把它发挥到了极致。这又是一个例子。
And I identify with that because I don't spend a lot of time, just the way that I'm made up. And I wonder if that's the way you are, that you had a Saturday to lick your wounds. And by Sunday, you said, get out of it and let's turn this thing around. And I understand that. I feel like I'm really lucky. Do you feel, do you recognize that that's something that you're just born with? Yeah.
我对此很有共鸣，因为我不会花太多时间去纠结，这就是我的性格。我想知道你是不是也这样，你花了一个周六去舔舐伤口。到了周日，你就说，走开，让我们扭转局面。我理解这一点。我觉得我真的很幸运。你觉得这是你与生俱来的吗？是啊。
I've never been a, I've never been a worrier. And I think if your stability is rocked early on, and again, wouldn't wish it, but I was more cautious and desiring even as a late teen into my 20s of setting a foundation that felt more grounded to me, otherwise I wouldn't be able to exist. So I had to find something that, a way of life that felt that I can stand tall on my own two feet without feeling like something's going to be taken again from me. So it's just developing it from the beginning. Yeah.
我从来不是一个爱担心的人。我想，如果你的稳定性在早期受到动摇，再说一次，我不希望那样，但我从十几岁到二十几岁时，就更加谨慎，渴望建立一个让我感到更踏实的基础，否则我无法生存。所以我必须找到一种生活方式，让我觉得可以靠自己的双脚站稳，而不必担心再次失去什么。所以这只是从一开始就培养出来的。是啊。
It's a good one. Brian, you have been so, so kind with your time today, sir. You certainly have set that solid base. It seems you were reaping all the rewards of all of those good decisions and going left instead of right. And we're all the richer for it with everything that you're, you're giving us. So keep going, please, keep giving us more stuff, comedy, drama, whatever you got, stage, screen, we'll take it all.
这很好。布莱恩，你今天真是太慷慨了，给了我们这么多时间。你确实打下了坚实的基础。看起来你正在收获所有那些正确决定的回报，选择了左而不是右。我们都因为你给予我们的一切而变得更加丰富。所以请继续，请给我们更多作品，喜剧、戏剧，无论什么，舞台、银幕，我们全盘接收。
Yeah. Thanks. And I just want to say, in all sincerity, I have appreciated the three of you and your talents immensely. And I cannot wait to see everything you guys do. I do wait because I haven't seen anything you do, but yeah. You Brian, you are, you're one of the all time great, good vibe guys. I swear to God, you've got the best vibe and, and that's the highest compliment.
是啊。谢谢。我只想说，真心话，我非常欣赏你们三位的才华。我迫不及待想看你们做的一切。我确实在等，因为我还没看过你们做的东西，但，是啊。你，布莱恩，你是史上最棒的、充满正能量的人之一。我发誓，你的气场是最好的，这是最高的赞美。
I think that you could pay somebody and you're just such a solid, great vibe dude. So thanks, man. Thanks, Brian. Love you, Brian. Love everything you do. Thanks guys. Thank you for doing this, buddy. You bet.
我想你能给某人的最高评价就是这个，你真是个气场强大、稳重的好人。谢谢，伙计。谢谢，布莱恩。爱你，布莱恩。爱你做的一切。谢谢你们。谢谢你做这个，伙计。没问题。
Thanks so much. Have a great rest of the day. Take care. Bye now. Bye. You know, I would love to work on one of his sets. He just seems like such a great, steady, calm leader that just would probably be no, no nonsense and lots, lots of good work.
太感谢了。祝你们余下的一天过得愉快。保重。再见。再见。你知道，我很想在他的剧组工作。他看起来就像是一个非常棒、稳重、冷静的领导者，可能不会有任何废话，而且会有很多很多好的工作。
Did you guys watch Breaking Bad when it came out? Like I was serious. Like I just watched it a year ago. Yeah. Same here. I was pretty late to it as well. I was late and then I motored through it. So great.
你们看《绝命毒师》了吗？我是认真的。我是一年前才看的。是啊。我也是。我也看得很晚。我看得晚，然后我一口气看完了。太棒了。
One of the greatest shows of all time. Oh my God. Incredible. Well, I mean it along with, with Bojack is consistently in the top five of all shows ever made. I would say that if we'll, if even if you weren't on this, I'm always stunned. I mean, it's so far for Wisconsin, that's Bojack Horseman, Bojack Horseman. Yeah.
史上最伟大的剧集之一。哦，天哪。不可思议。嗯，我的意思是，它和《马男波杰克》一直都在史上最伟大剧集的前五名。我会说，即使你没参与其中，我也总是感到震惊。我的意思是，威斯康星州离得太远了，那是《马男波杰克》，《马男波杰克》。是啊。
Well, they get it there too. Oh, thank you. Oh, thank you. Okay. It's not. Turn me into him. Oh God. There he is.
嗯，他们在那儿也能看到。哦，谢谢。哦，谢谢。好吧。不是。把我变成他。哦，天哪。他来了。
That sounded like it. Fuck it. Give us a little Bojack. Huh? Will. Yeah. Give yourself some fucking Bojack. Oh, there it is.
听起来像了。去他的。给我们来点波杰克。哈？威尔。是啊。给自己来点该死的波杰克。哦，就是这样。
There it is. No. Listen. He was great though. I've always, I used to run into him like on TV, you know, junket things with that when he was on Malcolm in the middle and I was on Will and Grace and always, always, always the guy is always the same. Always so kind and generous.
就是这样。不。听着。但他真的很棒。我以前经常在电视宣传活动中遇到他，比如他拍《马尔科姆的一家》时，我在拍《威尔与格蕾丝》，他总是，总是，总是那样，他一直都是同一个人。总是那么善良和慷慨。
Always has a smile. Yep. Always has such a great attitude. And I meant it. He's just got such a great vibe. He's the guy that you want to talk to. That's why, by the way, that's, that's why he works not only is he incredibly talented, but everybody wants to be around nice people.
总是带着微笑。是啊。总是保持着这么好的态度。我是认真的。他就是有这么好的气场。他是你想与之交谈的那个人。顺便说一句，这就是他工作的原因，不仅是因为他非常有才华，而且每个人都想和好人在一起。
Yeah. I do think you need a bank of goodwill in this business because you are going to strike out a bunch of times. And if you've got a bunch of baggage behind you and people hate you or they can't wait for you to get a couple of failures and it's like, okay, well, he's out. Why do you keep eroding your bank? Why do you do that? Just keep shipping away at it because it's just too big, Will.
是啊。我确实认为在这个行业里你需要积累“善意银行”，因为你会经历很多次失败。如果你背后背着很多包袱，人们讨厌你，或者他们巴不得你失败几次，那就会变成，好吧，他出局了。你为什么要不断侵蚀你的银行？你为什么要那样做？威尔，别再那样做了，因为那太大了。
No. Sean, you've got a very good reputation too. It should be known. People really like you. All right. It's true. It's true. Everybody really likes you.
不。肖恩，你的名声也很好。这应该是众所周知的。人们真的很喜欢你。好吧。这是真的。这是真的。每个人都真的很喜欢你。
That's very nice. Anytime I talk to people because people are starting to listen to smart less more than the one listener. I've just found out I think we might have two listeners. Hang on. Yeah. Because we have Wisconsin. We have Wisconsin.
那太好了。每当我跟人交谈时，因为人们开始听《SmartLess》了，不仅仅是一个听众。我刚发现我想我们可能有两位听众。等等。是啊。因为我们有威斯康星州。我们有威斯康星州。
Will, you've got a pretty good reputation too. Yeah, you both do. But it has been taking water. Has it? Yes. Taking water. You know what? It's because, you know what it is?
威尔，你的名声也相当不错。是啊。你们俩都有。但它一直在漏水。是吗？是的。漏水。你知道吗？你知道是什么原因吗？
It's because people are so intimidated by my plastic surgery. I think that's what it is. Right. It makes them feel insecure. I can't take how taught my neck and so they just choose to hate you and so they hate me for it. And they hate because they say it's affected my voice and I'm like, you know what, Jason great guest today, hilarious, awesome, sweet, kind, talented guy and we didn't even get
是因为人们被我的整形手术吓到了。我想是这样。对吧。这让他们感到不安全。我无法忍受我的脖子有多紧，所以他们选择恨你，所以他们也恨我。他们恨是因为他们说这影响了我的声音，我心想，你知道吗，杰森，今天的嘉宾太棒了，搞笑、出色、甜美、善良、有才华，我们甚至还没聊到
to his mezcal company dos hombres with Aaron Paul. Oh, really? Oh, really? Yes. And now I'm doing. Not to mention the show he's got coming up on showtime called your honor, I believe. I believe it is and it's not about a judge. It's not about a judge.
他的梅斯卡尔酒公司Dos Hombres，和亚伦·保尔一起。哦，真的吗？哦，真的吗？是的。现在我正在做。更不用说他即将在Showtime播出的剧集《法官大人》，我相信。我相信是这样，而且它不是关于一个法官。它不是关于一个法官。
It's not about a judge. No, no. I hear it's very. You know what Jason said when I asked him where he asked me where Amanda, his wife was and I said, your honor. So Jason, what a great guest. He he was very, very generous to say yes to this. We're happy to have him.
它不是关于一个法官。不，不。我听说它非常。你知道杰森怎么说的吗？当我问他阿曼达，他妻子在哪里时，我说，法官大人。所以杰森，真是个伟大的嘉宾。他非常非常慷慨地答应了这次采访。我们很高兴有他。
We didn't get to a lot. He's slinging booze. He's a big Dodger fan. Yeah. Well, he's only got two fake fingers, not three. That was news. Super good guy. Super great get.
我们没聊到很多。他在卖酒。他是个超级道奇队球迷。是啊。嗯，他只有两根假手指，不是三根。那是新闻。超级好人。超级棒的嘉宾。
Thanks, Jason, for bringing him on. No, no, you're welcome. Oh, bye, bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢杰森把他带过来。不，不，不客气。哦，再见，再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。